Joining us now is a very dear friend of the show,
astrologer extraordinaire Aliza Kelly.
Hi, Aliza.
Hi, guys.
Hi, Drew.
How are you today?
I am doing very well, how are you guys?
Thanks for having me back.
Oh, well, I mean,
it's like the line from "Zoolander,"
astrology, it's so hot right now.
(Ross laughs)
So hot right now.
It is.
It is though.
It's always been, you know,
a very meaningful thing to a lot of people,
but I've just seen the trends through the roof,
and I was really excited
because I heard some information,
and we actually texted about it,
but take us through what is happening right now.
Well, as usual, there is so much going on right now,
but you don't need to be an astrologer to know that.
This has been a really wild year,
and it totally tracks with astrology.
So, on December 14th, there is a solar eclipse.
We are in Sagittarius season right now,
so things are extra, extra, extra,
which is, like, perfect for holiday vibes,
but, because this is a fire sign,
we are all, like, really leaning into our passions,
our philosophy, we're excited about things,
so this is kind of like the perfect way
to be concluding this pretty intense year.
But that's not the only big date in December.
There's another one we should be paying attention to, right?
Yes, so there's a very big date in December.
On December 21st, which is winter solstice,
the beginning of Capricorn season,
and also a palindrome, 12/21,
we have the great conjunction,
which is the meeting of Jupiter and Saturn.
It only happens every 20 years,
and, what's more, this is going to be visible
for the first time, in this intensity,
for the first time in 800 years.
800 years.
What does that mean?
What does it mean?
Newness, change.
So, I mean, it means so many things, Ross.
It means so many things, Drew.
But one of them, and I would say most importantly,
is that they're meeting in Aquarius,
and this is the dawn of the Age of Aquarius,
this time for real.
(Drew laughs)
Are you trying to get me to sing?
Okay, so this is good news for people,
change, the first time in 800 years,
Sagittarius into Aquarius, winter solstice.
This is amazing news for people.
Yes, just when we need it, right?
Is there anything, Aliza,
that we should have as a mantra this month?
Well, you know, I think that,
as we move into this air age
when we're thinking about Aquarius,
we're thinking about communication,
we're thinking about innovation, progress,
so what I'm really inviting people to do
is take time to visualize a better tomorrow,
to use this date, 12/21,
to think about, what does a really beautiful world
in the future look like?
Because everything that exists first starts as an idea,
so we collectively can do that.
We can usher in this new era
with beautiful thinking, beautiful imagination,
and bring it to life.
All right, 12/21, you are my palindrome of love.
Hey, Siri.
Aliza.
Remind me, December 21st is a big astrological day.
(Aliza laughs)
Thank you.
Thank you, Aliza Kelly.